YOU LOVE COMING HERE
SEAN HANNITY TAKING OVER.
AT >> Sean: TUCKER, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," EXTREMELY
GRAPHIC NEW VIDEO THAT REVEALS
THE VERY REAL HORRORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND IT IS HAPPENING
EVERYTHING WITH A AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THIS IS A TRUE NIGHTMARE THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING NOTHING TO RESOLVE.
REAL LIVES BEING DESTROYED.
SENATOR CRUZ WILL BE HERE WITH
US.
HE WILL SHOW US THE VIDEO AND WE
WILL RESPOND TO THAT, PLUS A
BOMBSHELL NEW CLAIM FROM A
GOVERNMENT WHISTLE-BLOWER.
OH, I THOUGHT THAT THE DEMOCRATS
LOVED WHISTLE-BLOWERS DETAILING
HOW FEW HIGH-RANKING OFFICIALS
NOW ATTEMPTED TO COVER UP AND
DOWN PLAY POSSIBLE CRIMES
COMMITTED BY THE PRESIDENT'S SON
HUNTER BIDEN.
WE HAVE THAT FULL REPORT TONIGHT
AND ALSO A MAJOR ANNOUNCEMENT
FROM THE VICE PRESIDENT, TAKE A
LOOK.
HERE IS ATS.
>> I AM A WOMAN SITTING AT THE
TABLE WEARING A BLUE BLOUSE.
>> Sean: WE WILL PLAY THE FULL
CRINGEWORTHY REMARKS COMING UP.
BUT FIRST WE BEGIN WITH WHAT TOP
ECONOMISTS ARE CALLING A PERFECT
STORM AND IT IS ONE FOR YOU OF
PAIN AND SUFFERING.
TODAY THAT CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
INDEX DECLINED FOR THE THIRD
STRAIGHT MONTH THAT THE DROP WAS
LARGER THAN EXPECTED, DRIVING
THESE NUMBERS 91 MILLION OF YOUR
FELLOW AMERICANS ADULTS WERE NOW
UNABLE TO AFFORD EVERYDAY
HOUSEHOLD EXPENSES BECAUSE OF
JOE BIDEN'S INFLATION AND HIS
ENERGY PRICES.
ALL TOLD 40% OF AMERICANS ARE
HAVING DIFFICULTY JUST PAYING
THEIR BILLS INCLUDING HALF OF
ALL SENIOR CITIZENS THAT CANNOT
AFFORD ESSENTIAL EXPENSES
MEANWHILE FORECLOSURES ARE ON
THE RISE, NEW HOME SALES HAVE
DROPPED TO A 24 MONTH LOW, MOTOR
VEHICLES, WELL, THE REPO MAN IS
BACK AND REPOSSESSED AT AN
ALARMING RATE AND IN THE PEAK OF
SUMMER, THIS IS SAD FOR KIDS.
I USED 11 ICE CREAM TRUCK CAME
BY, MR. SOFTY, GOOD HUMOR, EVEN
ICE CREAM TRUCKS ARE NOW BEING
FORCED OFF THE STREETS.
THEY CAN AFFORD THE INSANE PRICE
OF DIESEL TO RUN THEIR TRUCK.
EVEN RETAIL GIANT WALMART JUST
WARNED INVESTORS THE PROPHETS
ARE DRYING UP IN THE SLOW DOWN
IS IMMINENT.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
SADLY IT IS ONLY GOING TO GET
WORSE FROM HERE.
BUCKLE UP.
THE FED IS EXPECTED TO ANNOUNCE
ANOTHER MAJOR RETAIL HIKE THAT
SHOULD TAKE PLACE TOMORROW.
WE EXPECT 7-5 BASIS POINTS,
THREE QUARTERS OF A FULL POINT.
INTEREST RATE INCREASE, MAY BE A
FULL BASIS POINT AND ON
THURSDAY, THE SECOND QUARTER OF
GDP, TWO DAYS FROM NOW IT WILL
REVEAL WHETHER OR NOT OFFICIALLY
THE U.S. IS AND.
THE ATLANTA FED IS PREDICTING
THAT CONTRACTION IN THE
SECOND QUARTER OF 1.6%.
NOW KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS
IMPORTANT, SHOULD NOT BE
IMPORTANT, BUT IT IS IMPORTANT,
ONLY BECAUSE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION LYING, THE
HISTORIC BAROMETER FOR OR
DEFINITION OF A RECESSION IS TWO
STRAIGHT QUARTERS OF NEGATIVE
GROWTH.
THE LAST QUARTER OF THE U.S.
REPORTED 1.6% MINUS 1.6% GROWTH.
NEGATIVE GROWTH.
THIS QUARTER THE ECONOMY ALSO
EXPECTED TO BE IN THE RED.
NOW INSTEAD OF CORRECT --
MAKING A COURSE CORRECTION,
FACING THE TRUTH AND REALITY
THAT WE ARE IN A RECESSION AND
FOCUSING ON CHANGING FAILED
POLICIES TO REVIVE OUR ECONOMY
AND, LOOK THIS BURDEN OF
INFLATION OUT OF A 40 ONE-YEAR
HIGH, THE RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES
WE ARE PAYING.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS MORE
INTERESTED IN PARSING WORDS IN
PLAYING GAMES.
NOW FOR TWO WEEKS THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN TRYING TO
REWRITE THE OFFICIAL DEFINITION
OF A RECESSION INTO SOMETHING
VERY OBSCURE AND NEBULOUS AND
SIMPLY IF YOU ARE A CHARITABLE
COMING WILL SAY THAT THEY ARE
SPINNING YOU.
IF YOU ARE REALISTIC LIKE I AM
COMING WILL SAY THAT THEY ARE
OUTRIGHT LYING TO US.
AND THEN TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE,
THEY ARE NOW VOWING THAT THE
U.S. IS DEFINITELY NOT HEADED
TOWARDS A RECESSION, JOE BIDEN
SAID THIS WEEK, GOD WILLING,
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
TODAY PETER DOOCY WAS ON HIS
A-GAME ASKING JOE BIDEN'S VERY
NERVOUS LOOKING ECONOMIC ABIDES
ABOUT THIS A VERY SHADY APPROACH
TO REDEFINE WHAT IS A STANDARD
DEFINITION OF A RECESSION.
IS IT A RECESSION?
CAN YOU DEFINE WHAT A WOMAN IS?
THESE ARE THE QUESTIONS SOCIETY
IS ASKING EVERY DAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
TO SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT'S
ECONOMIC ADVISORS, WE ARE
TELLING LAST YEAR THAT INFLATION
WAS GOING TO BE TEMPORARY.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
NOW THE PRESIDENT'S ECONOMIC
ADVISORS ARE SAYING THERE IS NOT
GOING TO BE A RECESSION.
ARE YOU SURE?
>> LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
WE LOOK AT A RANGE OF DATA.
WE ASSESS THAT DATA, AND WE LAY
IT OUT FOR OURSELVES AND FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE OUR
WORD ON THIS.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW WHAT, I WILL
STICK WITH THAT PART.
WE WON'T TAKE YOUR WORD ON THIS
OR ANYTHING ELSE.
AFTER THE INFLATION IS NEAR
TRANSITORY AFTER THAT LIE AFTER
JOE BIDEN ANNOUNCED IN DECEMBER
OH, WE HAVE NOW REACHED THE PEAK
OF INFLATION, THAT WAS 7%.
AND I WENT 9.1.
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX.
WHY WOULD WE TRUST ANYTHING THAT
THEY ARE SAYING?
HERE IS COLD HARD TRUTH THE
ADMINISTRATION WON'T TELL YOU,
BUT YOU AND YOUR FAMILIES NEED
TO KNOW SO THAT YOU CAN PREPARE
FOR WHERE WE ARE.
WE ARE IN A TIME OF STAGNATION
BARRELING TOWARDS A FULL-BLOWN
RECESSION THAT WILL PROBABLY BE
DEEP.
THERE WILL NOT BE ANY TYPE OF
SOFT LANDING AS THEY CALL IT.
AMERICANS ARE NOW STRUGGLING TO
PAY THEIR BILLS, FILL UP THEIR
GAS TANKS AND EVEN PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE.
INFLATION IS AT A 41 YEAR HIGH.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING NOTHING TO PRODUCE MORE
ENERGY, OIL, GAS, COAL, REOPEN
REFINERIES OR CURTAIL GOVERNMENT
SPENDING.
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE THING THAT
CAUSED INFLATION TO SPIKE IN THE
FIRST PLACE IS STILL IN PLACE.
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN CALL THIS
ECONOMIC SUFFERING PRETTY MUCH
WHATEVER THEY WANT, BUT IT WON'T
CHANGE THE DIRE REALITY AS ONE
TOP ECONOMISTS TOLD BLOOMBERG,
ANY PREDICTION OF A SHALLOW
DOWNTURN IS TOTALLY DELUSIONAL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE CONSENSUS IS BECOMING
THAT IT IS LIKELY AS THE SOFT
LANDING, BUT PEOPLE ARE SAYING
IT WILL BE SHORT, SHALLOW, MILD,
PLAIN-VANILLA, AND THE VARIETY,
I DISAGREE, THERE ARE MANY
REASONS WHY WE WILL HAVE A
SEVERE RECESSION AND A SEVERE
INTERNATIONAL CRISIS.
SO IT WILL BE SHORT AND
SHOCKING.
IT'S TOTALLY DELUSIONAL.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY,
PREDICTING THE COLLAPSE IN '08
AND THE BRIDE AND WHITE HOUSE
TOTALLY DELUSIONAL RIGHT NOW,
ACCORDING TO THEM THE
ENVIRONMENT HAS BEEN SAVED ON
THIS ONE NOW IMPORTING OIL FROM
WHAT?
RUSSIA, IRAN, SAUDI ARABIA,
OPEC, INSTEAD OF PRODUCING RIGHT
HERE AT HOME.
ACCORDING TO THEM, TRILLIONS AND
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN NEW
SPENDING AND PRINTING HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH INFLATION
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, HE
CREATED A RECORD NUMBER OF JOBS
WHEN IN REALITY WE HAVE YET TO
FULLY RECOVER ALL OF THE LOST
JOBS FROM THE COVID SHUT DOWN.
EVEN JOE BIDEN'S PERSONA AS
MIDDLE-CLASS JOE IS COMPLETELY
DELUSIONAL.
BECAUSE UNDER JOE BIDEN'S
RADICAL CLIMATE COLT INSPIRED
AGENDA, POOR AND MIDDLE-CLASS
PEOPLE ON FIXED INCOMES,
ESPECIALLY THOSE ON FIXED
INCOMES ARE GETTING SQUEEZED TO
THE MOST.
THEY ARE SUFFERING UNDER THESE
POLICIES.
THESE ECONOMIC POLICIES, THESE
ENERGY POLICIES.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO BUY THE GAS.
THEY ARE THE ONES HAVING A HARD
TIME BUYING FOOD.
NEVER MIND FOOD THAT THEY LIKE.
THEY HAVE ARTIE MADE THAT
ADJUSTMENT.
AND